if we're gonna get nasty baby when we do
some a little bit different we're gonna
be doing the R&B challenge what that is
is that alpha is going to read off some
Ling lyrics from classic R&B tracks and
we are going to have to guess what the
song is I'm not gonna have what what
wasn't happening it's not happening what
I mean it's not then obviously but I'm
what - you don't like R&B I was not
really being an IRB but you know some
classics not really preach has no faith
in his R&B knowledge you know aren't be
Rev let's just go come on be good yeah
no oh
Emory Emory one thing over you didn't
even know it no listen B when it comes
to R&B that you know why could you
achieve a mother who is that why is that
why that's cuz I like cheese yeah or
maybe I believe in love and romance
cheese let's listen there's nothing
wrong everyone had a high school break
yeah and everyone had it to heal it with
some R&B you know don't you know okay I
don't think they had a dance act okay no
diggity Black Sheep never
I'm better bambam c11 preach you got you
gotta have some faith believe in
yourself have a little faith in me
oh yeah that's why I don't live in the
know Beyonce I'd heard the song but I
didn't want to remember it because I
hate Beyonce's music carry on so it's
still 1 1 DJ Khaled scrub my scrubs TLC
sexually Ewing Marvin Gaye 4 or bonus
point
Maximillian max civilian sexual eeling I
got to I got to come back two points the
covers don't include or not include you
never said that bonus points thank you
let's go I'm okay if we're gonna get
nasty baby
here's the thing we were at 2-2 before
because we've been because we're
actually supposed to do two points for
saying the artist name and for seeing
the song name okay I will do it is that
what's four for preach got the artist
name and the song right I got the artist
name right so we'll say it's six five
[ __ ] you what I said it before I said
genuine before you
yeah you said pony yeah okay so then
you're left horny you get the whole
thing you get two points I get one I'm
at it okay turns out you the cheesy
mother mary j blige you've got this
what's the name of the song ah damn
sorry Toleration at the dam three
percolating family affair I was never
gonna guess oh cool so now it's seven
instead of like her name coming
brandy angel brandy angel of mine yeah
hold up step that looks like brandy but
doesn't look like brandy but sing yeah
yeah I know what this case okay the song
is definitely angel of my Monica
[Applause]
I went deep in that archives like yo
who's that black girl who I didn't give
it Bob but made some good farm yeah
Brandi Monica my top of the world with
the world capital of capital work the
birth of wigs mine
I hated that song it was a good song I
hate it it's a fire song even though I
wouldn't sing it in the club sitting out
top of the world the world a world that
was a fire song I gotta admit
mace had a good flow mace mace had a
good flow like as an emcee underrated us
never made a lot of great music but when
he was M seen and always improving our
little world
okay Kony black that wouldn't you thin
it's not right but it's okay if it's
okay just talking about oh my god no
brandy and Monica unacceptable and
pulled out the B's know this was dope
it's not fine Brodie so right before
with [ __ ] yeah
no right before she got in today you
know Kobe and get it great it was a good
song though bobgoblin so that's two
points for preach we were at 5/7
[Music]
music Grammys [ __ ] how about that maybe
one at the time of his death I don't
know I don't know this one either
oh really I don't know he died recently
I don't even see that pop of a month
died like four days ago really really
okay what the curve iris no just Oh
[Laughter]
it was Alaia Alaia okay you're the quiz
master Alya
[Music]
yeah yeah all right
huh
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right or Kelly
princess naila come on get that cheese
out me get 50 Piper let's go okay
killing you 8:13
and she describes herself as being
obsessed with Amy Winehouse and in 2019
she released her single featuring burna
boy Joe Joe yeah I don't even like her
music but I know it's her all right that
means we're at nine Thirteen's at the
end you did a great job by the way you
did a good job you did a great job you
you shall come back that's right thank
you thank you baby listen man she didn't
know what the fee was doing that's why I
lost and so if we're being honest I said
that from the get-go alpha is that
nizzle so what happened you didn't think
he was gonna win this but all you know
you know you already
she went my [ __ ] uh sure no it's just
that yeah yeah [ __ ] that I wants you
yeah but you're new Raymond how do you
know his middle name
who doesn't know Raymond it's no full
name is Raymond uh sure
that's random that you've had I
appreciate though preach got some
competitive firing him he was not gonna
go down without swinging and this [ __ ]
swing this [ __ ] I still think you
should knock on that point that's what
we're doing that's the rules from now
right if you guys enjoyed today's
episode leave your comments below do you
guys know your arm B knowledge if so let
us know what you guys want us to do in
terms of music maybe we'll do hip hop
maybe we will do funk whatever it is
Muse preach big music head I love music
as well so maybe we'll do more of these
let's go peace that's a good video
[Music]